So Monday was my fourty first birthday, and
a helium inflated Stormtrooper showed up at
my door, and I couldn't pass up using him
as both a prop and a metaphor for this week's
Direct Message.
One of the ideas which keeps popping up in
the discussions we're having on The Rubin
Report is the old political labels are becoming
more and more meaningless by the day.
The terms "Progressive" and "liberal" have
virtually nothing to do with each other anymore,
and if you're a "classical liberal", you're
certainly not a "leftist".
"Conservative" and "Republican" don't have
much to do with each other today, as Trump,
a "populist", who doesn't focus on social
issues such as gay marriage and legalizing
marijuana, is now the leader of the GOP.
For these reasons, as well as the real time
crumbling of our mainstream media, the battle
for freedom now is between the authoritarians
and the libertarians.
That is, the battle over the soul of America,
and the West in general, is now about people
who want the government to have more control
of your life vs people who want the government
to have less control over your life.
I think by now you know that I fall solidly
in the camp of people who want the government
to have less control over your life.
And thats brings me to the trusty storm trooper
behind me.
In the original 1977 Star Wars, the storm
troopers were the foot soldiers for the Galactic
Republic: a massive, evil, military regime
who wanted to control every star system in
the galaxy.
This would qualify as authoritarian.
The empire and the stormtroopers were not
keepers of the peace as the Emperor had promised,
but authoritarian rulers who wanted to endlessly
expand their power, hence their building of
the Death Star to blow up any planet which
didn't fall in line with their desires.
Blowing up a planet is a pretty good way to
get people to do what you want.
Now dare I talk about the prequels, but trust
me, it works for this metaphor.
2002's Star Wars Episode II - Attack of the
Clones takes place about 20 years BEFORE the
original Star Wars.
In this film, the storm troopers, at that
time known as the clone troopers, were the
good guys.
They allied with the Jedi in defense of the
democratic Republic.
Eventually, Chancellor Palpatine, who had
consolidated power himself and secretly ordered
the creation of the clone army, took control
of the storm troopers and the Senate, used
Democracy against itself, and he went from
a Chancellor to the Emperor.
In 2015's The Force Awakens, which takes place
about 20 years AFTER the original trilogy,
the Storm Troopers are again the bad guys,
this time in the form of the soliders for
the authoritarian First Order, which has risen
from the ashes of the Galactic Republic.
One of the heroes of the story, Finn, is a
storm trooper gone rogue, who suddenly realizes
he as an individual can chart his own destiny.
He puts his collectivist past as a stormtrooper
behind him, and becomes one of the heroes
of the story.
The point of all of this, is that it isn't
this stormtrooper you should fear, it's the
power which commands him.
Any ideology can be used as a force for good
or for evil, and that's why we should be reigning
in authoritarianism of any kind, even when
it's YOUR sort of authoritarianism in charge.
This whole metaphor took place in a galaxy
far, far away, but the lessons it presents
are ones we can use right here on Earth.
Joining me to discuss authoritarianism v.
libertarianism is author, professor and podcaster
Thaddeus Russell.
Our friends at Learn Liberty have sent him
our way and to loosely quote Obi Wan Kenobi,
"This is the episode you've been looking for."